france
and i'm interested in quantum computing
so define topics such as quantum
algorithm for
probleming optimization statistical
estimation
uh quantum competitive theories so lower
bounds in different conservational
models such as
query complexity space complexity
communication complexity
and recently i have also started to be
interested in post-quantum cryptography
so
in this presentation i would like to
give you a brief overview of some of the
work i did on statistical estimation
and if i have time i will move to a
second topic which is about space
complexity so those are unrelated
okay let me start with uh this work on
statistical estimation and it's about
the mean estimation problem in the
one-dimensional case
over the reals
it's a very standard problem in the
classical setting which is pretty well
known
and as the setup is defined as follows
you have some
unknown distribution
d specified by some probability vector
and this distribution is obtained as
outcome of some experiments okay this
experiment can be classical quantum i
mean i will explain later on what is the
possible input model
and so this distribution so let this is
a possible example it has some min mu
and i will assume it has a finite
variance
and so
there is a natural complexity parameter
which is a number of times you can
repeat this experiment to obtain
information about the distribution
and in the mean estimation problem the
goal is to uh process those those uh
information
uh in order to compute an estimate of
the minimum
okay so this estimate denoted by mute
zelda you want it to be as close as
possible to the to the mean
and the standard
error bound that you want to satisfy
this is shown here in red
you want to find the smallest error term
which is the distance between neutrilda
and you want it to hold with probability
one minus delta
okay so this is really the standard main
estimation
now let's see a few possible uh model to
study this this this problem i mean how
do we define an experiment so the first
model which is the classical one
in this case an experiment is just a way
of obtaining one sample from the input
distribution
okay so you can if you perform an
experiment it means you obtain any
independent samples
a second model which is of a quantum
nature consists of having a quantum
state called the quantum sample which is
just a current encoding of your
distribution
okay so in particular what you can do is
you can measure this quantum state in
the standard basis and you would obtain
a classical sample so this model is at
least as powerful as the previous one
and the last model which is even more
powerful consists of having access to a
quantum circuit
such that it prepares a quantum sample
if you apply it on some six basis states
okay so you have a black box access
meaning you can apply this circuit on
any state of your choice
so now the natural question is what is
the best error ban we can obtain in each
of these three models
and first in the classical settings the
answer is pretty well known the best you
can have is on the order of the standard
deviation of your unknown distribution
divided by the square root of the number
of samples you are getting
then the estimators that satisfy this
bond are called sub gaussian estimators
and there are many possible choice for
those estimators maybe the most
well-known one is the median of means
now if you move to the second model
which is like a quantum input model
it turned out that you cannot do better
than in the previous case
meaning the best you can do is just to
measure this quantum sample to obtain
classical samples and then run a
classical subversion estimators there is
no speed up uh at all in this in this
setting
and the last model which is the most
interesting one for for for people doing
quantum computing for those kind of
questions
it turns out that it indeed allows you
to obtain some advantage in a quantum
setting
and more precisely one can show that you
can achieve a better scaling in terms of
the dependence on any number of
experiments which is linear instead of
being the square root of n
again again it's it's optimal
so obtaining this boundary is not as
easy as it may it may seem i mean
classically it's pretty simple i mean if
you don't care about constant factor you
can just apply the million of means but
quantumly it's a bit more complicated
and there have been a long series of of
what were to obtain the this ban
starting more than 20 years ago
and in particular the dependence on the
standard deviation was complicated to
open i mean some of those estimators
do not perform good if the distribution
is heavy-tailed yes
do you get access to the inverse view as
well yeah you also have access to the
inverse
yeah
again i mean those those works can
culminate in this optimal dependence on
on the standard deviation
so i'm not going to explain how those
quantum mean estimators are designed i
just want to give you a brief idea of
the techniques that are used for those
kind of algorithms
and those techniques lie at the
intersection between control algorithms
and statistics so on the quantum
algorithmic side people use like phase
estimation quantum counting amplitude
amplification to perform those kind of
mean estimation
and those techniques are combined with
methods such as like outliers detection
or trimmed estimators this is a really
interesting area where you have to like
combine those two different topics
together
and there are many interesting open
problems which are related to
those questions
i mean maybe one of the most interesting
one is to look at the high dimensional
setting for which there is not not much
which is known in the quantum setting
and there are other questions like uh
the robustness of quantum mean
estimators or like application
statistical physics for estimating
partition function
application to the monte carlo method
etc so i would be interested to talk
with you about any of those open
problems you are interested in
so i think i have time to move to
the second part
okay so this is about a different
research area that i also find
interesting which is unrelated to the to
the previous one
so this time it's about a complexity so
like proving lower bounds it's not about
finding algorithms
um it's a particular type of
complicated result in which
you look at what can we do or what
cannot be be done
when you have a small quantum computer i
mean a small memory algorithm
okay if the memory is limited can you
still do some useful useful tasks
and
so this is an interesting question in
particular in the quantum setting
because we expect to have small quantum
computers in the near future
so being able to understand the power of
those of those computers is important
and the way this question can be
addressed
is by looking at trade-off lower bounds
which consists of studying two different
complexity parameters at the same time
so for instance you could look at the
space versus the query complexity
and you could ask a question question
such as if i have a limited amount of
memory
how many quantum queries do i have to
perform on my input to solve some
problem of interest
okay is it like more quantum queries
than in the unlimited memory case for
instance
a second kind of trade-off is sample
versus
space complexity so again
though the sample complexity increases
when the space is limited and another
possible trade-off is communication
complexity versus run complexity
so i worked a bit
in the first setting the space versus
complexity setting
and with my quotas we looked at a
trade-off for the problem that consists
of finding
many collision pairs in a random hash
function
okay so there are quantum algorithms
that obtain like speed up for solving
this problem however if you look at
those algorithms they need a huge amount
of quantum memory
and so we ask the question
the following question if you have a
small quantum memory do you need more
quantum queries and it turns out that
the answer is yes and this problem of
finding many collision pairs though i
mean indeed becomes more difficult to
solve in the small memory setting
there are still open questions i mean
around this topic and probably there is
still a gap between the lower bound and
the upper bound which has to be to be
closed
um a second result which i find
interesting and i'm
i mean
we should probably uh already know half
is about a result by rand has obtained a
few years ago for this second setup of
space versus sample complexity so it's
about the classical settings so we have
a classical computer
and the goal is to
uh to to solve the so-called
parity-learning problem
and what raz showed him if you have a
small memory this problem has an
exponentially large sample complexity
whereas if you have a sufficiently large
memory it has just a polynomial sample
complexity
and so a natural question is what if you
have a quantum memory instead of having
a classical one
and
the question is completely open
and it seems to be a really interesting
one with connection to quantum
cryptography quantum leftover lemma so
it's probably a very interesting
research topic again again if you are
interested in any of those questions i
would be interesting to
talk with you
again with that i thank you
[Applause]
yeah i know you can do but memory i mean
what is uh now in terms of uh
quantum memory like whatever you need to
do yeah so if you want to solve priority
learning over a vector of size and
gaussian elimination
and square
uh
elimination
and each of which is developed
and yeah so it's n squared bits of the
more important
so the the parity result right
says that n squared is enough but what's
the third result so it says
below n square over like 25 or something
like that
that's so just slightly better n square
then you need exponentially
classified
so the gap is really just about the
constant factor it's a
sitting we are using classical samples
if we have quantum suppose there is like
quantum mechanism for finding priority
efficiently
but with classical sample and quantum
memory we don't know of any
anything better than gaussian dimensions
you can you can
solve the problem efficiently
but the question is really about
classical samples
um is there like a succinct way to state
where raz's result gets stuck when you
try to
right it's a lower bound and the value
is stuff
is there yes okay as i heard of raz
result there is a kind of a hogless
measure which is which is used to
analyze some branching program which is
somewhere that you use involving
transportation
and this progress measure i mean turning
it into a quantum hardware measure i
mean you have many obstacles like uh
some data processing inequality that do
not work anymore
next we have uh
[Music]